[Applause]
how are you i'm very good how are you
good thanks very much for coming thank
you for asking you seem to be in a good
mood
yes go ahead no no huh your show yes
okay well
i forgot all right uh you know i was a
little i won't you know how to start
i've so many things to ask you but i
want to i want to clear the air first i
heard that that uh you had heard
somewhere you had it was a little angry
with me because you heard somewhere that
uh i don't like irish food is that the
case do they
that's that's what i heard
whoa
[Applause]
i know you had a tendency to get tipsy
but
speaking of tipsy
but don't you like irish food i well you
know what i was misunderstood i said
somewhere and then i apparently had got
around in ireland but i don't like irish
food it's just it's i said somewhere
they're not known for their cuisine you
know they're known for like throwing a
potato on your plate and a piece of beef
and saying get to it you know no no no
no but we'll see the best irish food is
guinness
no argument that you had the wrong menu
on the table guinness guinness this is
three of the four irish food groups i
understand this takes the one the only
one you know they say that they say that
they speaking of said valentine's day
they say that guess is an aphrodisiac
i have not found it to be so oh no i
know that happy that well the only thing
that guinness gets up is your hopes
[Applause]
do you know who we met first who oh yes
i met you well how can i forget uh it
was like the i was invited to the white
house they had a party for the prime
minister of ireland it and they just
they said let's round up every irish
person we can find
they put away all the good furniture
they put out the paper plates with the
presidential seal on it and uh i bumped
into you there it was very exciting i
was amazed how tall you were you
remember no one knows that i'm yes yeah
that's what i get
you're tall yeah yeah
i remember trying to get the president
who i
who i really admire your president
because he loves ireland your president
uh i tried to get him to drink guinness
that night you know
really yeah i said come on you must
drink some mr president you must have
some guinness remember the other table
of irish guinness oh yeah it was a great
they had kegs in the white house for the
first time it was a i swear to god the
police came by at like two in the
morning and shut us down
it was a good time it was great to see
the first lady and and the president
trying to learn the irish jig
i'm trying to teach them yeah yeah they
were trying to yeah yeah it was a lot of
fun yeah it was great
the holy and then the evening was over
and they cleared us all out of there and
uh to know about that man i know i know
you weren't allowed to smoke
so i used to sneak out on the balcony
and so take a quick drive a cigarette
then get back in again it was great it
was great it was grand with a good night
that's the best thing about the white
house is that there's a balcony to smoke
on
yes that's what you are calling you know
i want to ask you because uh because you
do have a you know i alluded to it
before but you have a reputation uh as
as do many of the great actors of your
generation of drinking some
while you work or as you work especially
in the theater world and i was curious
is that really true is there you know
wouldn't it be terrible for me to lie on
your show and say it's not true yeah
i remember i tell you a great story can
i tell you a story well that's sort of
what these shows are all about this
dovetails nicely for us yeah go ahead
why a story all right
we had we had there was there was the
two guys who we were there were three of
us legends for drinking okay and for
having a yeah you've had a wild rabbi
lazy in life one was richard burton of
course peter o'toole the great o'toole
and harris i know tula
hotel and i did a play together down in
bristol old vic which is a very famous
theater in england
and
we have and during the play there's
about 15 to 20 minutes when actually
we're not on stage so every single night
we come off stage together dash across
the street tuck the taxis into the bar
and we'd be throwing back beers and
beers watching the time making sure we
got back on time for our cue right well
one night we got so engrossed in telling
stories
that we forgot that we were on stage and
the next minute this the door burst open
and the stage uh the stage manager came
rushing on and said harris o'toole for
god's sake
you're on
your arm there's a full house waiting
for you the play has stopped dead come
on we dropped our drink quickly down our
throat rushed across the street
so we dashed across the street we were
ducking taxis ducking this and that i
dashed it i had to make my entrance just
before him as i hit the stage door over
the town i i heard my queue i thought
i'll never make it dashed up the stairs
dashed across
pause on stage
harris is not on oh tool is not on i
just dashed on tripped over a wire
slid right across the stage right down
to the footlights and hung over onto the
lap of two or three sort of bristolian
old women
an o'toole was to come on next and this
woman looked at me in shock as my sort
of head was in her lap
and she said out loud
good god
harris is drunk
[Laughter]
and i and i looked her and i said madam
if you think i'm drunk wait lord tool
makes his entrance
oh god
i love it i love it i love it you know
it's funny because you mentioned uh
peter o'toole but but uh
it's
you know with in the last couple of
years it's become more i think more chic
probably in the last 10 15 years and
correct me if i'm wrong more chic
actually probably to be irish there was
a time probably when you were starting
out i'm thinking in the 50s when when
being an irish actor trying to make a
living in england was very difficult it
was very rough we it was very i think i
was the first
irish-born actor
to play leading roles and to get academy
award nominations and that was the very
very first and when i got to england
first though it really was tough you
were cast as the policeman or as a navi
on the street or
you know a laborer you couldn't get it
you could not get a decent job
and i i remember a story that i was
doing in my first year out of school
drama school i was playing in macbeth
and i was playing a small part in
macbeth of the doctor
this snobby
sophisticated racist english actor was
playing macbeth
and he had to have a whipping boy and it
was harris because he was irish oh god
sake harris can't you allowed to speak
the english language correctly don't you
know you don't don't pronounce it like
that or for god sake can't you stand
with the right mark god i thought i
hated this man
i said i swear to christ i get you one
day
so now you must remember i'm playing the
doctor came the opening night packed
house harris is playing the doctor and
the most and the most important scene in
macbeth
is when lady macbeth commits suicide
and i as the doctor have to come on
stage for my tiny little part my only
little entrance and i have to say and
and matt bette turns and he says
how goes the queen
and i have to say
the queen my lord
is dead
and then he stops and he says she should
have died hereafter now it leads into
the greatest soliloquy for macbeth which
is tomorrow tomorrow and tomorrow creeps
with our petty pace from day to day to
the last syllable of recorded time
that's his q i give him the cue i
thought i'll get him
[Laughter]
harris the queen dies harris comes on
stage the actor says how goes the queen
and i said she's fine
[Applause]
she is terrific i said i stand up i said
she's terrific she's grand and i know
i'm fired she's great and she'll be
right down now any minute and you'll get
on great together and i got off the
stage quick and the last thing you heard
me say going out the stage door was taxi
you knew i
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god all right uh how much time we
do we have here jeff hmm oh great
because i don't i do not want this to
stop uh i i'm i'll come back
will you come back sometime sure please
do come back
i'm curious i didn't want to mention uh
i didn't want to mention it is
valentine's day and you have a
reputation for uh you know the many
loves in your life uh you've been
married how many times twice you've been
married twice okay and you've had a yeah
romance difficult for you oh no they
threw me out i mean
i mean
i have to i'm i must tell you i am
the closest friends of my two ex-wives
they were totally justified throwing me
out i mean i was impossible totally
impossible never there never here never
home always away somewhere i tell you
funny story actually my my first one my
first one i don't think you can miss
okay
my first wife was was divorcing me right
and she had this sort of very shrewd
lawyer and the and my first wife was a
sweetheart and i mean i she's a
sweetheart today she's my best mate but
he never her lawyer never told her but
he hired a private detective to follow
me around london to build up a kind of
case against me there was no need to
build a case against me just open the
newspapers and there was cases against
me just say it's richard harris
a justifiable divorce in her part
so i was tipped off that this guy was
following me
and he was watching every move i made
and i found out his name and i found out
his home number
and i kept it in my pocket well about a
month afterwards i was in the dorchester
hotel in london
and i was really drunk
i had i dragged about a bottle of vodka
a brandy to us actually right
and
it's about three o'clock in the morning
and i thought i'll have some fun
so i get his card out of my pocket
and i ring him up to his home
and a very tired voice said hello and i
said ah
are you mr so-and-so the private
detective
he says yes i am
well this is richard harris
you can hear
them he didn't know he didn't think i
knew
i said well i got to tell you something
i said i am pissed drunk
i don't know where i am could you please
tell me where i am
put into some mutes
if nothing else put them into some news
oh boy
i hope uh
i gotta mention this uh the hunchback is
uh so that everyone should watch this
the hunchback is on tnt this sunday at
eight o'clock p.m and uh i really do
hope you come back this is this is the
most fun uh we have on this show thank
you very much for doing it thank you
richard harris
[Applause]